oh hi everyone what's up
how y'all doing
welcome i am playing uh
um kingdoms of amyloid re-reckoning
tonight
i'm super excited um i absolutely loved
this game like i was so into it i've
always felt like
uh the combat was what i wanted like a
modern fable to be
um it has a bit less personality because
this game is
is literally structured to be the
precursor to an mmo it's actually a
really fascinating story with like
coach chilling and everything that
happened to rhode island the history of
this game is super interesting
but ultimately i really love it
uh how is the audio mix before i start
uh i'm playing this on xbox um i believe
there is a day one patch that doesn't
come until tomorrow but i'm only gonna
play for a couple hours anyway so
audio all right is okay tell me if you
need me to adjust anything but it should
be just fine
yeah i'm aware the chair is holographic
but i don't mind
um if i if i uh change it it's
it's worse it's better that it's
slightly see-through so all right let's
do it
yeah i i played this game when it came
out and i smashed through it to the
extent that
i also don't remember the beginning of
it that well like i will remember areas
of it
um i know that i respect a few times
but
because of that i'm like excited to
re-experience it as well i only played
it once but i [ __ ] i loved it i
smashed through this game
let's go i remember you start in like
this big old building
i don't know why you're there though
from the beginning we were wrong
there you go and only now well into the
second decade of the conflict
have we begun to understand the mistakes
we have made
we lived in harmony among the fae in a
world
awakened to new magic
i mean this doesn't look great but i
don't care
on this rising tide what force
might awaken is some real lord of the
rings [ __ ]
powerful enough to twist even the
eternal
and the
surprised us all singular among his
people
he was all that other faith were not
aggressive
ambitious visionary of course yes he had
power like
none we had ever seen terrible and
deadly sick
uh i would agree by no means the
masterpiece in the east
just very funny those crystalline
fortress of elvish sauron is sort of
right it's
very very lord of the rings oh god they
marched to war against the young races
of amalor
against the opening might be different i
really don't remember no matter the
power of their god
we might have been victorious but that
they
are creatures of magic not bound by the
laws of
life and death it's so long
on the battlefield would soon rise again
do you feel death as we do how could we
stand against
such a force for ten years the war
raged for ten years the answers
fought and died
making a lot of content lately um which
i should say thank you guys
people keeping like thank you for all
the content honestly it's helping to
keep me sane
you died um being locked in an apartment
by myself and like getting to make
content for people is like
it's like honestly thank you like i have
made more
youtube content and done more streams in
the last like three months than i've
ever done before in my life and it's
because it's really really helpful for
me
um so thank you guys for watching for
helping me
while in isolation it it is uh
i feel like been a lifesaver
just always have stuff to work on and
people to talk to about video games you
know
yeah i'm gonna play this the exact same
[ __ ] way i played it the first time
though let's be real
i do remember that you are dead and i
think you've lost your memory that's
what the game starts with
what do you think this one
uh i read twitch youtube and facebook
comments all at the same time
if you're always on the job boy don't
matter what it is
yeah character creator yes baby
okay i don't remember any of this i
don't even remember what i focused on i
knew i didn't really care about alchemy
but i 100 when i got like 20 hours into
this game there's this particular town
that you can get to that will let you
respec
all of your stats but i feel like every
time you respec
it's either more expensive or there's a
limit there was some catch there
um what do i i so i always want to play
as
the most wizardly option the owl main
sorry
the al main are a war-like and religious
nation of a storied origin
many al-mein come to the phelan seeking
freedom
while honoring the traditions of their
homeland
i was just trying to do it like the
intro lady so
did i nail it did i do a good job
hardened by the high seas just as
frequently pirates i'm gonna pass
on that sage craft alchemy and
dispelling sounds pretty legit to me
there's gonna be one of these similar
things
what was the first alchemy persuasion
blacksmithing it's gonna be one of these
two
the i don't know how to pronounce this i
don't know how to pronounce this um
proud and ancient people from the frozen
lands of the north they judge themselves
fit to divine
right from wrong under wind sun and sky
sage craft alchemy
dispelling it's funny that they call
them racial bonuses
uh daca right now to sophisticated
students of magic and diplomacy
me let's go
um
we're gonna go with this boy i wanna be
a wizard i don't like any of these but
of all of them it would be this one
okay ladies and gentlemen let's do it
good
i think that one was nice anyway eye
color i like a yellow or a purple let's
go yellow
eye shadow huh yes queen
i can't even see it
uh this is a cyberpunk chair yes thank
you for asking
what did they remaster i mean i don't
know what the updates actually were i
wasn't following the development of this
game
but uh should have chosen female i
always play as a male in every
uh game i play i don't know why
i think it's like the protagonist of the
stories that i like to have is always
a very particular it's always the same
character in every single one um
i don't try to play as me if that makes
sense
stubble color yeah let's give you some
[ __ ] stubble boss
all of these look bad so far but yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah good [ __ ] good [ __ ] okay
no that i'm alright with i'm alright
with it
i think i remember having actual issues
with what's happened here what's all
this
i think i remember having issues with
the um the hair in this game and that
the one that i ended up choosing i was
like he looks like he's in a boy band
but it's the only suitable option
it was that one that i went with when i
first played it 100 i'm gonna do this
which makes you look evil and i wish it
was it featured a ponytail does this one
have it
no oh it does yeah we can take that we
can take that you can have a sweet braid
bro
it's gonna be white that facial hair is
terrible and i hate it
well see then i could go proper be it i
like
to defeats the purpose of the stubble
but
i'm into it i'm into it yeah okay
cool
that doesn't appear to be changing is it
changing
i'm gonna say no i don't think it is
i do not know uh assessoir
i'm probably gonna pass on having any if
i'm being honest where is the no
options could be that one tattoo we like
a face facial scar
oh that's going to be well it could be
here let's see i like that i like that
one
that one's nice
i don't like it to be symmetrical is my
thing give me an asymmetric
that's neat i would like it to go over
your eye that's what i want that's what
i want
ooh that's pretty cool
i think i had it light blue yeah it's so
funny that it's like
i almost feel like i'm cheating on my
old character it's not so much time
playing this game
we're gonna do this one make it a little
bit less intense
yeah no that is working good okay
that's got to be it look i don't love it
but
it works it works
now i get to name him right
no surprise
oh thank you appreciate it all right
then
make sure it goes into the report
you know you'll want all the details
amazing how well the body helped up
um i'm just glad it's not moving
i'm just gonna get rid of this person
because they just keep
trolling in the chat over and over and
over again every stream probably the
same person from before
uh so matthew roche said i feel like
darkseid has got a slightly better
remaster
uh i believe this is the same company it
is it's chq nordic for both
so um
koen's the name of the character that i
always have fun fact
uh we're gonna get rid of you
tunes bro [ __ ] tunes
how many characters that 12 year old you
thought looked edgy
and cool so i basically make characters
that look as much like geralt from the
witcher as possible
um which i feel is relevant because
um i you know i play the witcher 1
through
i think i actually think two is almost
better than than one
um there you go
i'm pretty sure that i just banned the
right person but it may have been the
wrong person happened sometimes
all right here we go
that's it uh yeah the witch has been
with me for a long time so basically
every rpg
every character custom i said i'm making
and i like an elf i like a major like a
wizard y'all know what's up
it's not a fetish it's not a it's not a
sexual attraction
it's just um
i don't know just feels like a good
fantasy look for whatever reason in my
head
will i make geralt for cyberpunk i
actually
prefer female v's voice acting so i
think
that will be one exception to the rule
where
um i will play as female v
which means that i won't make a geralt
look like
i just don't really like the dude's
voice but i do like the chick's voice so
but that's yeah usually that will
actually almost be the first rpg
where i've ever picked a woman
i think it's that i like being as
different from me as possible maybe i
don't know
i don't know
all right lad i think that this building
falls apart i'm pretty sure
if i recall there it is
uh nostalgia
i need to prove my water bottle you are
covering my screen
i will take you rusty long sword
beautiful oh
oh that's that's the system you've got
all righty
should i have looked around here a bit
more maybe like is this an area that i
can even go to
what's y'all what's what's all this
secrecy is still important in our work
requiring specialized disposal of our
unfortunate failures
piling remains become a concern a lower
cap and so an incinerator has been added
to deal with the waste issue
cool cool i've got it
all right what's all this yeah what you
got for me boss
14 gold fox girls is cashed up okay
this just like fable
why they make them have such big feats
here's my question
later dude
good day i said good day
oh man dragon's dogma rules this game is
not as good as dragon's dogma
um to the person in chat who just said
that if this this isn't dragon's dogma
good
like i really enjoyed this game but
mostly just for the combat um
whereas dragonstone especially docker
isn't is like
this is a sort of generic rpg that i
happen to
have a great time with and really enjoy
the combat specifically i really like
the chakrams and i like the
those systems in particular um i do also
like the world but like
it's not groundbreaking i feel like
dragon's dogma is unique enough that it
is
groundbreaking
get wrecked bro this is like way more
nostalgic than i expected this game
feels older than i think it actually is
um yeah this game is is definitely an
rpg that will feel familiar to other
rpgs but it is also a [ __ ] good time
let's see how well it holds up
yeah getting loud
okay cool i can dodge let's do it do you
have luck on
is that a ting
i do not remember we ain't got a counter
system
it'd certainly be preferable
very limited so far huh
i can break like everything oops
oops
all right what y'all got you got cool
[ __ ] on you
sweet
it is it is this inventory system is
just a bit much
because it feels uh like it requires so
much effort
compared to uh modern games that that
was the thing when i first replayed
the um the witcher 3 though as well it
was like the menus oh my god
dude for a dead dude i'm [ __ ] ripped
look at his shoulders damn man
hey
what happened to me boss uh well you
died i don't know how or even
but your body oh my god you should
absolutely
get dragonstone please do please do
i have some questions myself i do thank
you
he'll be in his study on the ground
floor to offer coming in through the
lower levels
if we had it we should be able to beat
them to the top all right and so
he's like insulin
um well of souls tell me about that
it's basically the lazarus pit it works
i'm familiar with batman
i wish i could tell you more you showed
no signs of life when we
removed your new body from the wells
waters we just put it in the furnace
room with the others
we would have never done that if we
any advice for a small stream to bump up
the following i mean look
i don't feel like a person who can give
advice on that because um
my following uh took years and was not a
thing that happened quickly you know
um and because i worked for massive
companies and on international
television and radio and [ __ ]
it was very slow so i guess like
a don't care if you want to build a
following i would say
don't uh just have fun don't try
to get followers people will see right
through it just enjoy what you do and
keep doing things you enjoy
uh followers don't
uh bring your happiness it causes a lot
of problems frankly
no just enjoy yourself as a but b is you
know be consistent
work hard make a lot of content uh
i've built my following over like 15
years maybe longer at this point
it's been a while see if you can find
anything useful
okay
cool a shitty shield
i just auto equip i swear to god uh
let me put these on my feet
there's gonna be weapons are you gonna
be an accessor xx1
consumables probably not
where is it oh
there you go sweet it's pretty it's
pretty
true probably not quite 15 years i mean
i'm 27 now
but i've had a blog since i was about
13. so
again just don't even worry about it
just uh
just have fun
i don't know do i hear something am i
supposed to you tell me boss
oh look at chess who keeps leaving these
here
thank you oh i'm okay
i have gloves i have gloves thanks
adrian
um let's go inventory armor
torn gloves it is funny how this stuff
ages like so the character controls
actually feels pretty good
that's the thing that usually ages
pretty badly too oh
okay okay hello
aha wonderful there we go
the camera is so close
okay that feels better yeah the combat
felt actively bad without a parry system
so we good here
um but yeah i feel like menu systems
just they just evolved so fast it's ui
it just keeps aging really quickly all
right
okay cool let's go
give me my my magic bag that's what i
want
oh well my bad probably screwed up that
a bit
there is a lot of clicking yes oh you
can distance your camera i guess i might
do that
i don't tremendously feel like i need
you just yet but it does feel oddly
really close
thank you andre and happy birthday
adrian
um i had a fully locked down birthday i
did see one friend one friend came by
brought me a cake which was technically
from someone else
um but we you know
socially distanced did not even hug
it was uh that's it that's all i did and
it was fine
what's up
what you got cool i love those for me
let's do it
well i wouldn't say mine was depressing
um i didn't care uh but that's you know
that's what
quarantine birthdays are i wasn't i
didn't mind it at all i wasn't depressed
i had a good day it was just um
didn't see anyone which is obviously
very different but you know everyone's
going through it
aside it is what it is
thank you clam chowder
you want to drive in that's cool i don't
have a car so i can't even go anywhere
which is a huge one
okay i know that i never used these when
i actually played though so i have to
swap my primary probably
to the daggers
they do have like really cool flurries
with the daggers if i remember correctly
though so what was uh what'd you tell me
sneak was what was a sneak what's snake
gonna be
bud is it gonna be one of the gonna be
gonna be this gonna be i missed it
what okay there you go thanks
appreciate that
let's go
you don't know [ __ ]
correct
get out of here oh okay what you got
sweet so much free stuff
so much free stuff uh yes scott this is
the remastered edition
should say that on facebook i think that
um youtube was the only place that
didn't let me type in re-reckoning or
maybe it was facebook one of them
only let me type in reckoning it didn't
let me
specify that i was playing the new
version for whatever reason
it was twitch even i really don't know
okay hey well that was the camera
don't love that
good day changed my weapon back being
prime rings
just prefer a long sword okay cool
oh i can't go that way don't you tell me
that we eat that's what he's saying
okay cool never mind
automatic doors back in game of thrones
times
i don't know what you guys talking about
right now
did i say re-wrecking rather than
re-reckoning is that what happened i
don't know
it's possible
this game has loads of bits
with cool plants see modern fable dude
it's like exactly like the fable one
controls
uh even that sound is literally just a
color skate are you kidding me
hello hugo's
hughes hugos per your request we finally
got the spider problem
under control this seems like someone
else would have
power your request you finally got to
spider problem under your control
claude will try to take credit for
efficient no it's too smart for someone
who sounds like that
who just sounds irish [ __ ] spiders i
remember
having a big issue with this game in
that uh i am terrified of spiders and it
has
large spider boys um
and i think it is annoying that every
fantasy game thinks they need to have a
spider
as an enemy what if you didn't you know
i'm saying
what's over here though oh a chest sick
okay do we have some [ __ ] we need to
upgrade here is that what's happening
that is way better already oh i like the
block efficiency okay
mana regen merely lock we're gonna do oh
it's efficiency
we'll we'll do stuff that focuses on
mana when i have mana but look at me go
ah looking fancy
there they are that i [ __ ] know fancy
fermenter just died
um eric i haven't done a dj stream in a
minute
just because i've been real busy is
ultimately the reason um
yeah i plan to do another one soon
oh it's definitely also just that there
are so many video games out right now
okay
um
uh that yeah when i'm streaming i'm
trying to catch up on video games that i
would like to play
that's what's happening
these spiders aren't bothering me that
much because they don't look realistic
maybe i'm like
it's not giving maybe i've grown out of
like i now i'm afraid of the spiders and
grounded
these spiders aren't that bad the wolf
spiders and grounded are
absolutely terrifying
hey i tried to roll you ass
all right don't you spit at me you big
punk
i mean i know you want me to get out but
like what if there's loot
have you thought about that because
there is
sit
break everything i can't believe none of
these boxes have things in them though
that's just i just feel betrayed
yeah the the noises for the uh chino the
pony i think is what you said the noises
for the wolf spiders
are next level they're terrifying
it's awful
i'm not claude how dare you get away
that's what i intend who is talking to
who
this is too many people talking and i'm
right here
oh it is just hughes why is it spot that
way
you've got a lot of wounded knobs to
take care of
cool that everyone's acted unnecessary
but
cool okay is that even better
no it's not
it's a lot of [ __ ] already
why'd you make it a jump scare
uh listen keith i am from australia
not everything kills you it's
exaggerated okay it's fine
i never i did get stung by a jellyfish
once but that's it that's the worst i've
ever had you know
i don't know that i do need more help
but i want to take it because of the
percentage
magic is that what you mean
where is hughes oh you gave me some
extremely ahead potions in his study
just
keep going past the
we all have names super neat the lazarus
pit
cool thank you andre
okay okay
did you think that was a better view is
that what you
thought that was
i think i disagree
oh that's not good uh fall naravi uh no
i'm playing on xbox
with this actually like a very cool new
controller i just got
i have no idea who sent it to me i
assume dc
but it's so pretty it's uh it's wonder
woman themed
stunning
that's a lot of souls what happens if i
try to run into it
damn
what time is it over here uh fable 2 is
the best favorite you know
fable 1 is the best fable what is wrong
with you uh it is currently
8 46.
uh would i consider playing some from
soft games i have played
every fromsoft game well except for that
first game
but i i played demonstr absolutely
zero interest in streaming that kind of
thing
no i like to pay a lot of attention when
i play uh
games like that and also if i'm bad i
don't want to hear about it from
people on the internet because you know
they're hard so
though i generally would say i am pretty
good at from soft games i do have um
some sakura gameplay up on my channel i
was drunk that was fun
but no we'll never stream those
i'm aware the chair is staticky yes
feature not a bug
you want to see me rage quit i don't get
rage unfortunately i just keep going
until i finish something
why the expensive bat statue over a car
uh
i
i'm going to opt not to answer that so
i'm going to say there is a reason but
we had the time what's going on
right now
i feel like i know exactly what's going
on and that that's not that complicated
to explain
you're the only proof of what we've
achieved
but i can ensure that its only success
is safe
hmm yeah i haven't had any bugs so far
but where we're like
maybe like a couple minutes in
yeah jeff you can you can see me like
get disappointed in myself on platform
videos but i just don't get rage
i just don't get angry you know i've
said that in videos recently it just
doesn't happen for me so i don't
rage at video games i just talk down to
myself
just insult myself a lot but there's no
there's no anger in me at all
devastatingly for content purposes
um fight whatever
oh no i won't never mind it's most
important how do i juggle
playing so many games do you ever get
slumped on what to play next
it's all i do so it's fine i'm good
i'm not certain what's caused it but
somehow the closest i ever got to rage
quitting the only thing that ever makes
me mad is if a camera is not working
i get angry at camera controls
like if the game itself is preventing me
from being able to do things but
otherwise
i guess it's like if a bug prevents me
from progressing
or a camera
okay
who is this wow okay little guy
oh you tear these [ __ ] in their abs
up
okay surely there's something cool for
me to take in this room
surely you're gonna try and tell me that
you ain't got any
chests in here bro
i'm worried i've missed one but maybe
there just isn't one maybe there just
isn't one
if i remember correctly when you get to
oh thank you i didn't know how to sprint
when you get to this town you walk in
and like somebody is either vomiting or
is
dead in the front oh get a
oh i should have got my sword back out
that's not great is it can't really see
[ __ ] there
we are going to equip my
rusty long sword
because i want to just use my actual uh
my actual
spells for spells and
ideally eventually get the chalk roms
for my weapon
but i also like a sword battle mage
is my ideal class so
loot corpse i thought you'd never ask
great i haven't even needed to use it
yet am i a pro gamer
i also probably played this game on hard
when i first played it that was back
when i played
everything on hard right now because of
time
i do normal like a [ __ ]
give me a second i have my hand full
there mate
you want to pipe down
you can change to sprint to press a or
hole uh i'm happy with the man i am cool
with that
oh okay rock troll
ah i'm out of mana bleed for me
that's [ __ ] up
he's so weak like any rpg
something doing 10 damage is not a good
sign
i don't want to get too close to him
though he's big you know he's real big
oh i resisted
all right big guy
i guess i haven't actually tried to
shield him to
any kind of parry situation you know
what i'm saying
sorry what do i find oh i probably could
have done it there
um is there a hot cue for my
ah no
yes okay okay it is just d-pad it is so
much like fable
try me bro
camera sure is going to camera oh i
didn't expect you to slap me
a bit rude
yes
oh a finisher i don't remember that
all right okay
wrecked done
um all right cool let's go to the uh
the glade shall we i remember finding
this game it's stunning
just like absolutely beautiful the first
town there's a chest called the special
deliveries chest with
what it scrolls too fast
fyi the first town there's a chess
called the special delivery chest with a
bunch of purple and gold gear in it just
a heads up
um i appreciate that i feel like i would
prefer not to know
is what i'm gonna say oh thank you of
course i have played the hell out of
this game
um but for content i don't remember i
think i would prefer to rediscover
things
i appreciate uh what you're doing here
though
just for just for future reference
level up son okay look at this
ridiculous old [ __ ]
a failed experiment now results in an
unstable potion i know i didn't use any
of that blacksmithing i did use detected
and dispelling
okay that's because i already have some
of those is that right
i don't think i can afford that as my
guess
that's just shards stealth i don't care
okay let's see what what we want to do
because it'll be based on what these
things get you right because
these ones are empty oh it's just time
duration
i have no idea what i want to do right
now
i feel like that maybe
i'm not going to use stealth i know i
used blacksmith
that's what we're gonna do because i
know i used it last time so let's do it
oh boy sorcery please
okay a lot to unpack here
uh it is definitely possible to get
every skill maxed yes dos
definitely um i think i may have gotten
all the achievements in this game you
know
but again you don't even really need
that to plan ahead that badly all i know
is
this thing this lightning this right
here
[ __ ] come on okay okay i get it we
gotta
i'm trying to get to the middle let me
is really good is what i was gonna say
um but you can like respect as you go on
so
i saw somebody just mention fifa will i
stream fifa with rahul kohli please
i was just talking to him about that
today actually um
thank you for asking stay pressed i
i i might do that yeah when uh new fifa
comes out that rahul curley and i
might stream it i have not played very
much of it
would be a good time yeah one video game
dude i spent a lot of time in this game
a lot of time in this game it's good
stuff it's good stuff
is this game open well they're very
linear uh ryan it's open world
um has a linear story but it's it's very
open world ultimately
you play fifa i do not i don't play any
sports games
but uh i'm willing to learn
you know liverpool and that
okay let's [ __ ] do it
what's here arcane weaponry
charge special attack well that is what
i want i want the chalk roams yep
uh i'm not gonna [ __ ] with finesse at
all let's check might because that is
what i want to do is be a battle mage
you feel me you feel me
that sounds pretty sick snag an enemy
and pull it back to you
that's cool uh i don't want a hammer i
do want a long sword so let's do that
too
and then i'm also gonna do this done
good stuff
is this what i was remembering no i'm
thinking of the first town
so many people have voiced it's so cool
uh mega driving this is the remaster
uh the door collapsed behind me i
suppose that's a little bit of kindness
still trapped inside of this piece
um tell you about all stuff
so much fun it seems fine to me
tomorrow hughes was one of the greatest
minds of our generation
the will of souls was a dream that was
almost too good to come you'd be
resurrecting people out here that's
pretty [ __ ] up frankly
a cure to tragedy
well someone was always gonna come for
it but truth is no it's not too good to
exist it work
i'm here
good chat have have fun miss you
okay cool plant there is this one
particular plant in this game that i
like
almost got tattooed on me uh i can't
remember what it was
that i i emailed someone who i knew
was a dev at the studio
trying to get out of it and couldn't
i don't remember what it was just this
one [ __ ] plant that i was like that
[ __ ] is
beautiful
yeah cool
what's what's green ting you get an
achievement finding all of those
yes yes it's coming back to me
this game is very big
and i feel like even on like an
objective level it's better than i
remember
i shouldn't waste my time looting
everything here but boy
do i want to you know so i'm doing it
oh it's a bad wow rude
did you know that the bears um hate
shields they hate them
just can't not a thing to be done hey
bud
you're going to give me anything for
that you're going to give me free [ __ ]
or
apparently not cool how did you come
back
how did you find me here
the world
found
i don't want to be mean though
we're just gonna let him go thank you i
don't want anything to do wait he gave
me something anyway oh sick
cool let me um harvest all these plants
it's so many plants
nope that's the wrong button okay cool
look another one a lot of plants
oh nothing found what are you waiting to
have what are we doing that for
good idea
oh i don't really want to kill a wolf i
like wolf
okay well you guys are a bit too ranged
for this to work for my current setup
so i guess i'll electrocute you
you're all you the backing up situation
is not like
in my favor that's all i'm gonna say you
if you could approach
and stay approached that would actually
help me significantly
oh i didn't i'm sorry dia
i didn't mean to excuse me i just had to
electrocute your friend
so he could okay at least they don't
make painful dog dying sounds
why did this wolf have a sturdy helm on
it
why did it and where
where was it keeping the sturdy helm
i mean thank you i guess but i have many
questions
that don't make sense oh a long sword
you had a you had a a long sword
on you did you
great um
i'm happy to have it so thank you
stoned candle mines
i'll probably die if i go in here but
like i want to
though so we're going to do it
i know that the mines have traps in them
that you maybe can't necessarily always
undo but this is early
right it's early in the game it's not
going to give me a mean mind
it'd be a nice mine surely
all right well that looked very locked
amazed that it wasn't
cool yes deadly traps that's right
that's right
am familiar mean i'm pretty sure they're
what's that nothing i was gonna say i'm
pretty sure that they're all just
tripped my uh
uh trip trip mine so that's you just
look for a trip
but i'm not positive if that's oh
that's some deadly premonition [ __ ] if
ever i've seen it
hello hi there hey thank you andre
bear trap yeah they actually might be
bear traps too
i forgot about you it's like jackals
from halo
but wow you are strong
it's all right it's cool we'll get
through it
you're all very easy to block so
you know it's fine
ah well okay
if you time it wrong they do they
certainly do get you
um but i'm happy to have the xp so
that's what we're really
about here did that not work because he
hit me
that's not how lightning works lightning
doesn't just expire because somebody hit
you
damn i'm trying to time it and failing
it's fine you are generally very easy to
block
okay cool whatever
that's it nobody else had anything cool
for me great
i guess we'll keep going
camera dude camera it's true the camera
is not good
i need to turn the brightness up this is
it's too dark i can't see
[ __ ] uh there you go
oh yeah i couldn't even see any of those
logos what there's a fourth block jesus
i need to have this way up i hope this
doesn't look terrible in the stream
though
um
but that's i couldn't even see that that
that last one you know what i'm saying
there
that's infinitely better holy [ __ ]
oh well come on mate
you weird cat thing you
oh my gosh a fork in the road
is there a map there is okay okay
okay we're gonna go we're gonna go this
way we're gonna go this way we're gonna
do it we're gonna go this way
pretty but the music got dangerous
what's happening what's happening
we try right i don't know how to do this
at all
because this is very obliviony by the
looks of things
so so it's like close is what you're
telling me
okay okay i think i got it
i'm not very good at stopping it once it
has started
so it's i think it's like here then
cool wasn't worth it but
i learned oh excellent great okay
no more that way got it turning around
um and i don't think i can do anything
from here no sir
well i don't wanna be the blame not
anymore it's your turn
take a seat i'm settling the
final score
i've had a lot of paramour stuck in my
head lately
pretty much out of nowhere uh have i
done full loop now i've done it all
right
yeah i think so getting lads
get ready to die
i waited that whole first few seconds
and nobody did [ __ ]
and then you have to time that right
there did you
the combos get a lot better for the
record everyone i would like you all to
know
hey aerial combo that's on street
fighter [ __ ]
um they start off pretty uninteresting
but stuff gets real cool as you level up
your like
skill with a certain weapon and again
the chakrams in this game i don't know
how soon i can get a chakram but
imma do it the minute i can because it's
the best
okay
take shroom uh it's this way right right
right
right right uh did i explore whatever
this lip is
i think i did i think nope i didn't okay
cool how this compares to dragon's dogma
it doesn't i feel like dragon's dogma is
a very different video game
god i love that game everybody just do
yourselves a favor if you haven't
already play
dragon stop my darker risen please
it's so good
i still try
all right
nope oh i did time it right cool
all right mate okay i don't feel like i
deserve that
get out of here anyone got any loot
anyone oh yeah practical physics
nope never mind look like it did for a
second okay this one's gonna be easy
then
well it's just probably not gonna be
that precise then we're gonna go like
maybe like here
okay so maybe like here then
okay so they're here then which is the
exact same spot as the last one
really they both unlocked at the exact
same spot
smoldering daggers sweet
it's like family fable was fun you
didn't like the followers thinking
dragon's dogmat dude i love the pawns
um i love fable one i think the humor is
better i think the quests are more
interesting than this game
fable has more personality the combat in
this is way better
is the truth way way way better
um this like honestly if i would have
asked playground for anything with the
new fable i would be like just make it
like kingdoms of ammo in terms of the
combat bro
please
is this on ps4 yes i believe it is on
ps4 and on pc i don't know about switch
scott do you know why there wasn't a
sequel to this game
basically bankrupted an entire goddamn
state
i should just make a youtube video about
it nobody would watch it like it would
get so few views but
um i do think the story of what happened
with this game is super interesting
for anyone who doesn't already know i
guess
like it maybe it's worth just making
just to like inform people
on what happened with kurt chilling in
rhode island and the mmo that never was
oh i'm not gonna be able to get back up
that way okay oh it's super interesting
stuff
you've never heard it jeff it's it's
nuts
i have to look back this way
what if i just teleported like wouldn't
that be
cool because i don't think i can
go off that which is probably what i was
meant to do huh it was probably supposed
to go that way the first time
all right it's fine mine's ain't that
big
that's what you get
please make your way
yeah it's really not that big i don't
know what i was bitching about
it's fine
cool we did it xp probably
oh welcome nate very nice
the game looks more similar to
darksiders too
i guess the aesthetic is sort of like
darksiders 2
in the opening parts the entire second
part of darkseid is too
sorry i don't know if maybe you're
talking about the remaster specifically
eric
um uh the entire second part of that
game is like the map is just
a dead underworld kind of thank you
andre
uh frank we will be doing another among
a stream on sunday we'll probably do
them every sunday for a while
and because the among us
youtube video that i made got like
no views considering it took me so long
to edit
uh i'll probably just leave the streams
up which is like beneficial for some of
you obviously
um yeah 43k views for a video that took
me like six seven hours of editing time
is not what it
oh hello did we get raided from lawrence
is that what happened
welcome everyone what's up
hi i'm playing kingdoms of amal the
re-reckoning
it's a re-release it came out today i
loved this video game when it first came
out so i'm replaying it right now
uh this way it's gonna be this way
yeah i uh it's actually a pretty hard
sell to get me on a re-release or a
remake because i'm like bro i have all
these new video games to play and i had
recently restarted a witcher 3
playthrough but then when cdpr announced
that it was coming to next gen for free
i was like
imma wait on that and then re-restart
that but this game
from the minute they announced i was
like on board yes
am i not in the cannon of this game i
believe i too am a fate weaver
you know but knowing the future being
able to change it in two very different
things
uh there's trouble at the tower trust me
i've known that for a long time
nobody can change okay brag about it
sorry i'm telling you something you
already knew you respected the way the
world looks
it's a shame you'll be dead yikes bro
wow i look awful in this cutscene
why are your eyes so open
do i look like him do i do did i do a
good job of role playing myself
right am i right now it looks like he's
looking at me
that hurts my eyes
oh [ __ ] the old man took it pretty well
honestly
well that means hughes is dead i don't
remember any of this
i love that just frequently asking
people for help is a thing in this game
and they usually just give you potions
what is he doing for me what are you
gonna give me is it just is it just a
minor healing potion
like the other guy it's so
funny like you're halfway through a
conversation and you're like hey bro
could you like help me out a bit like
unrelated to the conversation you're
like what if you just like tossed me
some help
and they're like yeah all right
because you're so persuasive and they
just give you some potions it's just
like consistent
i just woke up in the towel
correct it all makes sense it does
the cards this morning i drew the
gravedigger the running man
i am all of those things yes prepare
yourself they're coming
oh no the same dudes i've already fought
several times before
whatever will i do does cobalt were
harder than you
oh yeah fate energy okay yeah i feel
like this is a thing that i'm sort of
remembering
maybe sort of i blocked that so that's a
bit rude
another victory no y'all got daggers
these boys
is different reckoning mode do i turn
into a dragon
i don't remember i think that maybe i do
though
i think that maybe that's what happens
no i don't okay
okay i got it you just go glowy
uh what game am i thinking of where you
turn into a dragon
moving here an unraveling enemy and
press a to perform a fate shift look at
all this nerdy lore
this uses your remaining fate energy to
do but cool
sick bro that's
can't tap quickly it hurts
uh all right
what are you hey man i'm just a guy
trying to be a guy
get through the these difficult times
what i'm saying is this a short game
uh no teeton i believe this is like a
like 70 hour rpg it's like pretty long
uh
is the yep of the gods all right chill
out dude i [ __ ] came back from the
dead
so come here i'm going to do a reading
you might be able to change the threats
but fate will still have a plan i think
he can't read it or something i promise
not to tell you if i see you again
oh no i do want to do it though that
would be my guess
he was an academic but he had a problem
i like his little
is this game good i think this game is
good and i'm happy with this like this
obviously feels old
for sure feels old um but yeah
i always thought this game was really
good so yes i
should be right
i swear i haven't had that much
that's what i thought fate's weave is
always hard to see
it's in motion but undeniably there
yours is just what can i say
i'm
what's the premise of the game chuck
it's just an rpg
the premise is that it's it's magic rpg
that's it
that's the whole premise of the game
oh yeah i forgot about all of this
yeah and this is where you like
literally
specify you're like you get cards where
you [ __ ] specify what kind of like
[ __ ] you are and what i i got
battle mage was the one that i ended up
it was a mix of might and sorcery that i
went with battle mage was what i was
after
yeah neat ah
good stuff man um so from
tier one if we've unlocked destinies
it's manner
in it what does this mean
it could mean nothing or it could mean
okay then why say it the world hey goth
you might be a sign of that
or maybe the cause i've never had a
reason to doubt my own readings
but we should consult with arnold he's
not a friend but he's got a good eye for
the tapestry
i love the tapestry that's sick i'm
going to see if i can be of any help to
the world
cool bye what could this
all mean what's that what's that
what's oh was somebody sword
hanging out there don't trip on that
emily blunt eat your heart out
okay wait i'm going backwards i'm going
backwards i'm going backwards i'm going
backwards don't worry about it i figured
it out don't worry about it chat
i figured it out before you had to say
anything it's fine he does still have a
question mark on his head though
that's gonna bother me i need to keep
talking to him
let me just ask you questions okay
you wrestle hero of men cool wasn't good
enough so you became fate with a uh
cool you couldn't fight fate cool
he's a damn good fate cool okay
yep got it okay i'm familiar with what
fate is have heard of the concept before
faye weaver is actually a pretty cool
concept
i just want the question mark to go away
i don't know if i actually have to read
all of this for that to be a thing but
i'm going to anyway
right
didn't matter i think it's probably just
because i have a main quest with him
later on also
um let's just keep rolling and not let
that drive me
too insane is all i'm gonna say
oh these are the teleportation stones i
think
a navy recruitment letter
of all the songs i think that i can
i can teleport between them i'm pretty
sure that's the one that you get the
achievements of finding all of them
i've got a bunch of [ __ ] in my
inventory again
that looks stupid
both look stupid so it makes no
difference to me shut up jeff i don't
want to hear about the question mark on
the minimum please don't do this to me
okay i
don't want to hear about it i don't want
to hear about it
um sweet
upgrades
and that's that's gonna be it that's
gonna be it
cool guy hang on what moves
okay neat
quests if i remember correctly
this is actually um this game was
originally published by ea
i believe and the legend of dead kell
is actually dlc and i remember even when
this came out being like oh cool let's
go do this legend of dead kel thing but
it basically
you literally leave the tutorial of the
game where you've just gotten all of
your abilities and it immediately gives
you
a prompt for paid dlc
uh which is a [ __ ] mess of a thing um
obviously it's completely ignorable but
just damn y'all really [ __ ] went for
it uh of course if i'm wrong there
that's my bad but that is
i believe what that is if i remember
correctly
this game did come out a while ago
hello cutie hey
you look like you're wearing ammo
all right let's keep going let's keep
going let's keep going there is stealth
in this game
uh klondike ball um but it
it's very uninteresting to me so i'm not
really gonna [ __ ] with it
all right this i love how pretty this
game is
i'd like to fast travel can i fast
travel between anything i thought it was
only those stones
like the fact that they made it this
colorful
a lot of games are scared to do this
because they think it'll look childish
but this is like
really pretty
i like it this is what i
thought was a thing yeah yeah
hey what's up with this dude oh
i don't care it's great whenever
anyone's savage okay yeah that's good
i'm glad you don't
care what my race
they may be strange but they certainly
don't deserve this
you guys need me to tie my air
conditioning off nobody's complained but
it
i can hear it
well i did just see someone in the chat
just say what the [ __ ] is that noise
you're referring to the video game or
are you referring to my air conditioning
you might be referring to the woman
going
it's fine okay cool
what happened here it appears she was
attacking some manner of short blade
likely a dagger
people simply stood by if she called for
help if she could chill out
can you imagine
i don't know whether we possess the
knowledge to treat such a word
frankly i don't even know if i can save
a mortal with such grievous wounds
i would like to well help
only one with all the troubles we've
suffered in this village people are wary
of adversity
they'd rather just ignore it got it
that's [ __ ] up i'm going to suggest
something a bit
untraditional there's a they named
can you tell this [ __ ] to shut up
though i'm trying to help her but she's
not making it very uh compelling
she's making a terrible case for herself
making all that noise
thank you manny i should do a mini dock
on
video game industry law don't think i
would enjoy that uh aj greg this will be
a full video on youtube so like the
stream will just immediately be up
i won't be taking it down so you're good
there hope you stay in town
i would just like to leave this woman
um that's all i would like to do
yes bro yes
okay cool yes dude what dude yes
okay sick that
looks [ __ ] ugly but i'll take it
this thing's called the night that's
pretty neat
so we got a lot of [ __ ] we can get rid
of here then uh we're gonna
we're gonna keep all of it keep all the
purples for now well i guess
this is gonna be the beast it's gonna be
the beast
add to junk add to junk
that's cool oh we got the chalk realms
that's all i care about that's all i
care about
we finally got him that is it that's all
i've ever
wanted so good
put that junk that did we get some cool
armor
[ __ ] all right 33
15 15. 33 sun
sun and it looks cooler okay it's gonna
be all the shepherd stuff then
i guess i should probably look at what
these things do but if i put the [ __ ]
is it is it the is it the is it what i
think it is is it
is it the the n7 stuff
oh my gosh
i don't know if that's what it looks
like because i actually never had it um
if this is the mass effect iron i think
you like got it for
pre-ordering maybe
tower oh my gosh this is so cool
look amigo i'm a mass effect
yeah all right best game ever game of
the year done
systems yes yes yes yes yes
oh my gosh look at this [ __ ] cool guy
bro
what are you doing wait get out of here
um i'm gonna go to the bathroom everyone
uh you may you may stay here and admire
my incredibly cool wait can i sit on the
seat for you guys maybe
no video game too old uh if i just like
stand like here
um i understand if you guys would like
to take screenshots i'll take my webcam
away
so that you have full view of my
beautiful whatever elf whatever the [ __ ]
he was called i don't remember
they go have fun
um
me
me
for me
me
welcome
sweet
maybe we
me
foreign
me
hey guys i'm back what y'all talking
about
how's everybody doing
talking about streaming talking about
um uh grass someone missing grass
somebody said they have to put their
wife to bed what does that mean
okay yeah cool potatoes um
all right
good stuff good stuff okay
well i'm back so hey everyone
uh we just want to check some [ __ ] out
you know i want to go inside some
buildings and my cool llama
show you guys how chakrams work because
they're the [ __ ] coolest
they do somebody has a nice smile
she also has some of the best prices
probably should have mentioned the
prices first
don't give a [ __ ] about her smile
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
who owns the rights to this game at this
point reyna guy
gun vikes uh that would be thq
nordic
this is much bigger than it looked from
the outside
hey bro you got quests for me i will
take quests
it's true yeah if you have the sword and
stomach for this sort of work
we could use another to color it with
fancy words
but you'll find those who have taken
noted at the same time as me twins with
twins
oh look at my microphone good luck i
love that for me
uh oh i feel like i should think it over
oh but you said that i will be
held in the highest response well then
i'll join
head straight
yeah but look at your shitty haircut to
earn it
you must do something commendable there
are two brothers
scoundrels
sounds good i love that for me
hello you look pretty pull up a stool
stranger
sorry i'm standing awkwardly right in
front of you in your pocket
are you here about that sort of i like
your haircut it's it's like mine she has
a fringe like mine
house is even further over than mine is
though
i like it yeah what's up
i'm just a simple farm girl from the
plains of arizona
i left home as a girl and traveled
all right what you got though don't feel
like i need any of it because i just
i just sell all my junk um
like if i'm gonna compare oh
that is pretty good but do you have any
chakram
is question and is chakram ever as good
as my chakram
they're better but my chakram
do so much you know elementals
well i'm not upgrading anything yet i'm
not doing it yet it's
let me just roll out your feet um
okay what's back here then what's all
this what's all this what'd she what she
would you got back here
that's not what i wanted no nope what is
it
what is it it's upstairs
it's gonna be upstairs
i mean basically all right put my feet
up on my desk
you guys can't see it as far as you know
this is a perfect posture a very
professional streamer
what happens if i'm there you go this is
my chair so much more than my face
i could cut the top of it off i guess
but whatever
um not really
but what do you got though no i'm good
i'm good fam i ain't got any of that
i just feel like something about the
vibe of this game
aligns more closely with the fantasy
novels that i read than most other
even fantasy games do for whatever
reason oh thank you andre
um
it's just like the fact that there was a
healer there who can cure diseases and
stuff i don't know it's just
the fantasy vibes are on point
okay
let's continue then shall we what's
up with oh he's up there cool tight cool
cool cool cool cool sweet sweet sweet
sweet tweet
hey girl you look kind of cute is this
the right place to pick up chicks
oh yeah it was difficult enough to
adjust life
was it now we have to be on our guard
what is this world
something about them titties all right
bye
dude what is where is where you want me
to go of all the way over here
this map's just a right mess what's this
what is this little slither
don't know hey bro
welcome to this sick nose ring fam
i would invite you in but the order has
been too trusting in the
one never past what might be a test of
faith
you have arrived just when i am in need
of aid
so perhaps it could be
you need aid i have aids have worked for
years to establish a presence
it's not being without its challenges
cool let's do it is that what it was
i was trying to remember i knew this
game came out around the same time as
something for some reason i thought it
was dragon age but um
skyrim makes sense
yeah it very much just came out at a bad
time and ea didn't really market it as
much as they should
before very much on them too
i don't know what you asked me for
because i wasn't listening okay your boy
got lost i'll help you bro
yeah no worries dude cool please
okay bye what's this
i don't appear to be able to go through
okay
let us head in the direction of the main
quest
which is maybe this way yeah
maybe
i'm not entirely sure
like have i been here
um video game maps huh
they sure are gonna video game this [ __ ]
is beautiful though
it would have been such a good mmo all
right we're just going to go down
we're just going to main quest it the
first time that i played this i did
everything but the main quest so this
time
chakram's bro [ __ ]
yes
it's so good dude i love them so much
i mean like when you get more abilities
there's this like real cool one where
you can um
no you don't no you don't get [ __ ]
slapped by a disc woman
that's what i thought
[ __ ] yeah um there's this ability where
you like throw them and throw yourself
backwards as well but i was always just
like oh my god so cool
it's good stuff that's what i'm saying
it's good stuff
all right what year to come out i think
it's 2012.
i believe oh y'all also trying to get
[ __ ] up
that's cool they look like the little uh
hat monks from sakura
heat [ __ ] okay
this is a lot of pressure is my biggest
problem with this
or the ardent conqueror you mortals
named him king isa in the youth i feel
like i almost
shouldn't unlock things because i just
don't know what i want
he is your legend of might and eminence
come listen to a tale of issa it's all
about germs and shards i don't care
give me persuasion
three points available okay okay okay
we ain't getting money no way five
points in sorcery abilities
and for some reason i still can't get to
the lightning to level that up
so that's fun for me
um
like i don't know why it won't let me go
to it you know you know what i'm saying
we're just gonna level that up again and
then go to might
wow
shadowflow weaving a burst of shadow
magic to wound and stagger enemies
in an arc before you sounds pretty cool
uh wendy's chakrams though
i feel like i found it before or was it
was that the thing in sorcery it was
wasn't it
yeah that's it um okay i want to do
something in my
but i don't know what i want if we're
not going to use that i shouldn't have
even leveled that up to begin with
let's just do this again then done skis
i'm not going to be able to upgrade
these anymore yet i don't think
but if it was sorcery it would be
okay good fun cool
what's the situation here what's the
situation here no we're doing the main
quest that's what i'm doing i'm not
gonna finish this game for a second time
it seems so unlikely
so we're not gonna 100 it again right so
let's just do this the right way chakra
[ __ ]
oh yeah there's one where you can make
it spin around you in big old circles
yes yes
so what's up with you are you gonna give
me free [ __ ] for that finally
someone that looks like they could stand
up to a moderate thank you i've been
told that before
such as yourself me and a crew are
mounting an expedition to a new land
south of here
maybe i don't know fine i feel like i
have too many quests and i'm gonna like
spend the rest of my night sobbing in
bed full of indecision about how many
things that i have
that i can potentially maybe do
the chat rooms are cool thank you
i can't knock though
what is with your tan though dude still
rips though
you believe me a wolf
cursed to wear okay okay cool
i believe you
i don't know how i should say no i
should say no
i should say no thank you
okay bye maybe i'll help eventually
but right now i'm just trying to main
quest and not cry
it could have been griff could have been
didn't quite end up that way
i have to you know it's it's a problem
harder to read than a human and few or
many pockets to pick
these ballads fade they are not only
rich i feel like i remember this
i've heard snippets sure whatever
the ballot is called yeah i feel like i
remember balance being like mad
important or whatever
um but it's not time for that woman i
have
things to do
oops specifically
i want my main quest and i guess i'll
kill these wolves sorry i love you i'm
sorry i'm a big fan of your kind huge
fan of your work
and of folks of your variety
i'm really sorry for slaughtering you
i love you a lot and i'm sure in another
life you are a good boy
whom i would pat
i don't like it and i like it and i like
any of it
but it's done so here we are
oh look at us going the same way what is
that what is the green what is green
what is the green hello
yes i will take your protection
yes thank you all right keep going keep
going
i feel like it's pretty accurate alden
ring that this is more of a port than
anything else
do i think it's worth a replay
i rarely think anything is worth a
replay because there are so many video
games that why would you not just play
more of the video games
but i've been really excited about this
um like i said i think i might try to
just finish the main quest
and not do everything like i did the
first time that i played it because
that's a lot of time and there are so
many video games
um but i really do like this game and
yeah i know that as you
evolve the the combat it gets just
cooler and cooler and cooler as it goes
on
for sure
ah yes pax is happening soon
i've gotten text about it
hello
yeah tricky buzz it does have a lot of
side quests it's a huge game
um yeah it's like 100 hour rpg like 100
it's a big boy more deadly premonition
too oh i just dropped my control it's
fine didn't select anything
uh i've been thinking about it
um yeah it's been ages since the last
time i streamed i definitely
intend to continue streaming it so we'll
why they were see i uh might try to this
weekend maybe i don't know we'll see
definitely intent too soon
yeah you don't know me but something
tells me
i know you're better than me you don't
know what i'm
is that are you wearing a belt as
panties
that's gotta chafe hey
i do look pretty suspicious right now
don't i
you know um a real steve i can't tell
you how the graphics compared to when it
first released because i don't remember
i imagine it's better but i sadly do not
remember uh it
looks good though you know you're happy
with it i was hoping to avoid this
but i think i'm going to have to take
you to tell them
what's still oak it's a sacred place to
eat faith
i was hoping take you but i guess it
comes down to me
cool i'll meet you there okay this is
twice now i bury the bodies left in your
wake
are you telling me that this is a chest
i feel like i shouldn't just take other
people's [ __ ]
you know that doesn't seem like a cool
guy thing to do
but i'll take your beads i guess you're
dead so what do you care
alright so my next quest is also go to
this other location and meet me there
i have not played wasteland 3 yet um
james i really should i've been excited
about it since it was announced too i
just feel like there's so many games
right now
and i'm currently uh maybe like an hour
from finishing battle types
um
which i've actually really enjoyed a lot
more than i expected
we are going to attend
where is wrathia that this place
is cool as [ __ ]
the cradle of summer is also pretty cool
and then i think it's like
it's not the hololens itself ah it's
odessa that's where all the gnomes live
also very cool
i like this game i do i do so we need to
get there
huh cool
let's do it
how long have i been streaming i don't
know over an hour probably
probably like over an hour an hour and
47 minutes apparently
apparently that's what it says
there we go oh goodbye one video game
dude
have a good one lad am i going the right
way yes
it's so weird that it tells you all
those drop points but whatever you do
you video game you do you
i hate what i'm doing right now this is
very difficult for me
is can a rock okay
um like passing through side quests and
not finishing areas before i move on is
like just not the way that i play an rpg
but i've already finished it it doesn't
make sense to do it the same way twice
if we could be more chill about it we
should be more chill about it is all i'm
saying
spiderman
you all suck
that was rude that was super rude who
just gave me 16 gold
oh yeah let's do this
and like end your life now or whatever
so we do this
it's a it's gonna be y got it got it got
it got it got it cool
neat love it
all right bye everyone hey dude
you're absolutely right spencer you're
absolutely right
have i played the witcher 3 of course i
have yeah
i have not seen mulan people seem pretty
uh
unhappy with it i'm unclear on why
though
i've not picked up any information about
why but mulan was my favorite disney
movie as a kid
we need
i should stop accepting quests it's not
good
oh well oh well oh well oh well
okay cool what you got on you bro oh
i love all of the these things is it
this place that has the regen
it might be here i don't know if it was
this early in the game but the place
where you can respect
it's in a town that kind of looks like
this at the very least
neat ah alchemy
um i don't have any recipes yet
i can practice that can i or not
i have to get experiment that's it
that's how you learn them so like if i
combine
power and damage
boom oh it didn't work okay sick
so what is this
raw damage combine it
with
matter excellent let's do
restoration and health seems like it
would work right
there we go
so now we have one
cool neat
yeah this game it's good it's good game
it has many a system and i like them
is this [ __ ] asleep or dead is
something wrong what have you done
no thank you andre thank the gods
someone from the outside finally made it
through
i thought you'd be but it's good you're
here i'm silly
sick name and i need your help
and i need your help normally i keep a
stock of anti-venom at hand for when
silk farmers get bitten
but with the recent attacks so have been
empty
so there is an ingredient i still need
oh the poison glands of the spiders
that actually seems like easy
i'm afraid the only way no that's like
mad easy
like that's the easiest thing anyone in
this game has asked me to do at all ever
and i would love to do that for you
because for some reason these spiders
don't scare me
let's do it does everyone talk calmly
and cool i mean yeah it's fantasy that's
how it works
they all have to sound like that it's
the rules
okay i just need a spider to show up
really
or can i take a gland from one of the
ones i already killed maybe
that's gonna be a no it's gonna be
unknown
okay let's just continue on on our merry
way then
chad v is it gonna be no this way maybe
this way
i don't know how to get there exactly
can't go there
couldn't possibly
local map [ __ ] [ __ ]
across that one
i think i don't know
it is absolutely like elder scrolls
means fable
you are correct
that is on point
it is not dragon's dog
no no
i just walk past an exclamation point
look at me go i'm getting stronger
i'm growing as a person why does it look
like it goes up
i don't think i want to go this way but
i guess i am
oh it comes back
all right [ __ ] give me your glands
eat chakram all of you
well okay that was good timing on your
part
harry
the little the little ones are worse
than the big ones
is my hot take this spit is a
is a [ __ ] don't do it
don't do it little guy don't do it okay
is one of you gonna give me a gland
yeah i just oh she needed 15. okay well
now i don't feel so bad that's too many
you can have them at a later date it's
fine
hello i was told of
ancient days when wise priestess
goddess lyrius uh would i recommend a
secret lobster
look i've not tried many chairs um
and i'm sort of with the understanding
that gaming chairs aren't
necessarily like built for your posture
long term like they're
ultimately made of plastic so i don't
feel like i'm a good person to even
really ask about
opinions on chairs because that could be
like a thing that
you know you should take a bit more
seriously than i have
ultimately i already have scoliosis but
like
i would literally and i know this is
such a wanky answer but it'd be like i
literally like
see what a doctor says or a physical
therapist or some [ __ ] right
um however just
totally speaking of my personal
experiences
i really like this chair it's really
comfortable
um
but you know also take you back
seriously and stuff
so i don't know that it's what you
should be going for
okay
hey there ain't no fish today
who the [ __ ] gave me that name
you should feel good about that
i mean yeah telling someone to seek a
medical professional's advice
is wanky because it's such a cop-out
answer but it's also my genuine answer
sure accept every quest whatever who
cares
that can't be comfortable i'm gonna let
you sleep though
i'm going to let you sleep [ __ ] i want
to clear it but
it's fine i have to keep going this way
let's keep going alana you're being so
strong right now i'm so proud of you
look at you not doing everything it's
admirable
excuse me bro you can swim in this game
i don't remember that
sweet
i love a good button heel
okay let's go to get this blessing
shall we can i climb this
nah video game ain't that advanced go
around
then shall we
how are you not sinking like a rock and
all that ammo well you see
i'm very strong
it's always this way not this time
it's always that way or the other way so
there's that i'm just gonna swim around
here then
that's cool with me cool with me let's
go
yeah you can swim but not jump spencer
100
video games
sweet keep moving
don't mind me wolf just just walking
past don't want to kill another
all right well i said not to mind me but
you [ __ ] have to get aggro didn't you
you just have to see me
i'm sorry huge fan of kind
hmm okay
okay cool
okay so you want me to do those ones and
then those ones and then those ones
all right
[ __ ] that's fun though i would like to
try it again
oh okay so i unlocked it but i got
cursed
got it or maybe just took down oh no i
am totally cast
sweet
i'll take it it adds character maybe
girls will like me now
it's hard the highest difficulty setting
i believe so yeah ooh all right
blake barra get away from me
i would like it if you would not touch
me with your plague
framerate does not like that extra
chakra move
ew
okay cool stuff
let's keep rolling let's keep rolling
oh dang
it was bound to happen eventually uh
let me jump some [ __ ] i guess i know i
do have a lot of stuff now that i don't
[ __ ] need the flame is clearly
superior to
either of these to jump down
um
secondary it's going to be the exact
same [ __ ]
do you like the rigid cowl we'll keep it
we'll get rid of
that totally get rid of that
also pretty neat the running manhood
damn okay
the valley cow i don't really want to
get rid of most of this because it's all
dope so we won't get rid of our special
stuff
with our legendary stuff we'll get rid
of everything else
because i know you can eventually get a
house where you can add um
you can add [ __ ] to
like a permanent chest that you can then
take stuff out of
no rt zyra and that was a fable
anniversary
correct bryce that is what i just said
we're on the same wavelength man
what do i think of the avengers game
just watch lauren's video he didn't like
it look i don't like it
but um i've also not given the single
player a shot so
i feel like i'm saying i don't like it
for something that i haven't fully tried
but what i have played
i don't like bruce asked me if i wanted
to stream it again and i was like i'll
be honest bruce
i don't enjoy playing that game how have
i been mentally i'm good i'm doing good
doing great good stuff
all things considered usable item
okay well i already learned that but
that will only be usable at a very
specific place
can i repair anything
sweet what do the beads do nothing
we want the lock picks we need to keep
those get rid of those
i will read a book
never mind
uh let's just destroy some shitty stuff
then shall we
stuff that won't really get me much
money
it seems fine
i feel like i'm making like a sick beat
here
cool inventory got 20 spaces left
everything's coming up milhouse
and i'm just going to keep picking up
these because you know why not don't
worry about it
yeah is inventory management a hassle uh
it's not
japan in this game i mean it's like it's
an rpg so it's a thing
but i don't think it's a hassle again
because like i said you can get a house
where you can permanently put stuff in a
chest
um and it's also if i remember correctly
again i played this game when it first
came out which is quite some time ago
and i feel like
some people like get real judgey with me
when i don't remember things from video
games perfectly but you have to remember
i play a lot more video games than the
average person so at a certain point
they meld together and that is uh it
makes it hard to remember the specifics
of one game versus
the other million that i played in that
year um
oh you're right there bro
uh if i remember correctly is what i was
saying
uh this game certainly gets to a point
where you'll just have the stuff you
like and never feel the need to change
it
um so at a certain point you don't need
to worry about your inventory at all
because you just have the cool stuff
and you don't you can just scrap
everything else
but there are also a lot of people you
can sell stuff to maybe just not this
early but
i could fast travel to a city if i
wanted nina
what's that gonna do that's pretty neat
sick bro thank you
i was beginning to think you were just
something i came here like so quickly i
don't even know how you got here
before me what are the other games i
play miss holy ghost
welcome i feel like you must be new here
hello i'm alana and i play
literally everything that comes out
every
major new release including like lesser
known indies
i will play
i don't have charge attacks yet i
haven't unlocked them i have used the
ones that i have but
that's it
oh welcome blindfire you must also be
new here
uh my favorite game is daily premonition
why are we here one of life's greatest
mysteries you can change fate
in here i can get a glimpse of the whole
week and see
where you should yes it doesn't look
like much
less so i can do it bro let's do it
great let's go
i went to ludwig and he just had 119
gold
cool why are you carrying that full fam
okay let's look at the level ups shall
we
i don't i don't know what to do with any
of this
so
let's do that yeah cool great sorcery
bro can i level up yet
yes i'm about to be able to level this
up
right right right or can i not afford it
is that what you tell me
i can't upgrade it i need to upgrade
something else
but i still can't it won't let me go
down to the
to the bottom one there uh which is
truly the worst i can't get to that
particular
lightning um and i don't care about
that's just with staves though i don't
want either of these things
what did i level up in finesse
damage from stealth i don't know that i
did that i think it might have come with
that
so if i go here i would love that you
know
that's still for [ __ ] i don't care about
though actually because all i care about
is chalk rooms
i guess i have to level up some [ __ ] i
don't care about
um which of these do i want to do then
which of these do i want to do
going to the far right does not help me
sadly
use the stick
you're right i just have to literally go
diagonal with the stick
that's a ui issue that is what i want
though
uh that's a lot that does make this
cooler though
but thank you for pointing that out
otherwise i never would have figured it
out that was really it was
literally the d-pad didn't work okay
last manner
that's cool but no spear protect you
guys
done
i think i'm gonna do that too just
[ __ ]
no no no no let's spend one and might
again
yes good yes
cool great excellent
got it look at that little mosque
cute little guy hey wolf
sorry i knew you were going to start
some [ __ ] so i started some [ __ ] first
sorry
sometimes you just have to fight a [ __ ]
who's my maid in smash
you must be new here she keeps saying it
now kirby
all about that kirby life ever since
this place was abandoned
stay close all right this place has been
abandoned for so long that some fake
weavers think it's just
a legend i feel like this place has like
spike traps if i remember correctly also
it's all coming back to me there's like
spike traps on the floor
or something you know
you know
wow that sucked you got me so good i
couldn't i couldn't even shield
am i infecting them who's that
why are you all green the wolves just be
getting stinky
yeah or perhaps the shrill is doing
these
more chakras in video games boys so
[ __ ] good
sorry buddy
cute little guy why
are you still squealing
i am sorry okay
cool well are you gonna tell us which
way to go [ __ ] bag
or are you just gonna make me do it even
though in theory you know where we are
cool great excellent useful useful
companion
i don't know how i got that song stuck
in my head earlier i was singing
paramore and now
three all right big boys
frame rate dude be a problem here huh
not today would be cool if you could get
out of my [ __ ] though
really not appreciating being backed up
against a wall
all right that was a good hit to the
face that one would have hurt
oh yeah i have my fate
oh let's do it hey i'm trying excuse me
i'm trying to fate
oh no oh we're stuck okay well we're
gonna have to attack him
because i can't leave if i don't
this is not ideal uh that was not
great can he help
did you have anything on you sick
i wanted to use my fate but i couldn't
because i kept getting bitch-slapped
life's a [ __ ] and then you die am i
right that's what i'm saying
okay hi hey buddy
that's just us that's a chest cool
uh i don't think we can go anywhere else
from here if i'm
reading this correctly right we can't
get up there right now
right jay
that is where i want to go but no no
we're going the wrong way that's going
to be how we get back
i've done it again i've done it again
oh goodnight sneaky baloop
the buzzing i don't know what buzzing
you're hearing
again it's possibly my fan you shouldn't
be hearing buzzing i don't know
sometimes people say that and it seems
to be like subjective in a strange way
like it has that through something with
my microphone does that through some
people speakers and not others i don't
i don't know uh where am i going
down
yeah let's go
all right kill some more goblins i
suppose
oh yeah i can use it now yeah yeah boss
let's do it let's do it
weave some [ __ ] fate boy
all right okay well you know i'm busy
fate weaving if y'all could just chill
out
cool what are you doing there wolf
what's the plan
i hate it a lot
the loop of the wolves dying is the
worst
i have to spelling skill let's do it
yeah now let's leave and never come back
because this is the worst
chakrams dude what a [ __ ] what a
[ __ ] weapon
that's what i'm saying
all right the theater can show us the
whole tapestry of faith
made there we can do nothing to change
or prevent it foreign cool well stay
close
i didn't mean to talk to you then stop
telling me to stay close you weird dude
combat is still so limited but we'll get
there
wow that really looked like it was aimed
at me dickwad
frame rate drops
and screen tearing we got the whole crew
together
am i talking a game or chat but
i certainly alternate between the two
but obviously when you are playing
video game you can only talk to chat
so much otherwise it would be a just
chatting stream
you know what i'm saying i try to
balance them
i think i had these chakrams at one
point in this game that had like
both lightning and fire so when you you
spun them the colors were like rainbow
it's good stuff okay cool
great i don't even really need it but
fine
whatever i'll take it just chatting
streams are the best i haven't done many
at all i don't know that i've ever done
a just just chatting stream but i feel
like
i can't do that because i would find it
not productive and thus i would have an
issue with it
i can only do things while doing
something else
it's a real problem i have
just talking to people not my strong
suit
um but i guess i usually label my
editing streams it's just cutting
because i don't know what else you're
supposed to label on us
another victory
about when you're djing what do you mean
what about it
what about it i don't even talk when i
do those the mic isn't even plugged in
wait a [ __ ]
what are you doing this cage here is
that a chicken
that's rude
i don't think i can help you though
little chicken i'm sorry
another victory all right
i don't intend to commit crimes though
i think i probably should do a little
bit of sage craft
stolen items always succeed forcing
locks
this is why it's like you don't know
which of the [ __ ] is useful when you
start this right
that's why i didn't
i 100 respect at some point it's just i
don't know
okay what did i unlock for sorcery
spheres protection that's right michael
flame
that's pretty rad what are the mite ones
though let's read this
max health um
threat of immediate death grants you a
chance for search of hell smash the
ground
yes boss yes boss
great sword mastering brutal mastery
don't care let's
do another one here
done guardian
that is what i want beautiful
yeah because you got mastery yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes
good good good good good good so do i
need to
equip i haven't been using my long sword
have i
or any of that or that
obviously i've used that a number of
times
um well i just have it now like what's
the deal it does beautiful
now we have a second spell you'll love
to see it
have i ever thought about streaming halo
on legendary solo or with friends
uh i mean i could um
but i tend to play halo with friends
not on stream you know
i've been doing that recently and played
halo reach
the other night let's use the let's use
the y yeah
look at me go um i don't stream
everything i play
you know i'm just trying to find a
balance between it
that's why generally all of my streams
are
new releases you will see me get my
first impressions live on stream
of generally every game that comes out
but i don't often continue
am i going the wrong way
uh no this should work right
we should be able to jump off this jump
point
what are the differences in the
re-reckoning it doesn't seem like very
much from what i can tell
hey lads where you saw some [ __ ]
hell yeah didn't even hit anyone
great love that for me
good range on that lightning spell
that's what i'm saying
bad range on that one and not enough
mana
all right everybody they really were
just killing each other there
appreciate the assist
cool let's keep going
it's an interesting placement of that
arrow
we're almost there great
let's keep going
um
drink your water ladies and gentlemen
it's good for you how's the game so far
great it continues to be kingdoms of
amalor which i really like
this
okay it's cool i'll kill this dude
what do you mean this is as far as you
can take me and then you continue to
come with me
whoa he's taking like no damage am i
seeing that right
that's crazy i mean he is oh no that's
fine
he just has a lot of health help
let's fate whatever
just keep fighting them
punch him with some lightning chakrams
all right yeah boy
dead
yeah right the dick go for it go for it
nice
nice nice okay went through the stomach
in the end but you know
we made it work cool
whatever all right you sold me you can't
come with me anymore but you're still
coming
i don't understand why are you still
here
oh he thought he saw something he didn't
uh jeff i didn't continue playing tell
me why because i
didn't like it um not my kind of game
which is like
i feel like what i said on that stream
the whole time
um but
i think i probably will finish chapter
one just
to have done it um but i just i'm not
into that kind of game and i'm not an
issue
i'm a kind of ting
i change fate yes everything he wants
everything he would
you're quite welcome sir
you're much more dangerous than i think
i
all righty then where are we going
through this way up the stairs
okay
all right let's keep going
rude don't hit me
i didn't mean to do any of that at that
point in time
love it hey
hey hey
i should probably stop being more
careful because i am running out of
potions
nope hey
everybody's dead keep moving
i do feel like a lot of this game if i
remember correctly is just dungeons that
look like this
um but at least they're always colorful
i appreciate an early 2010s game
that isn't afraid of color when so many
of them are
cool
well i was blocking there but it only
does so much when i'm using my chalk
roms and i'm waiting for the combo to
finish
so chill chill
it does feel weird to use a ranged
attack on someone when they're so close
to you but it's fine
maybe i should just keep more distance
from them you know
all right keep rolling we're about to be
level five
i'm really moving on up in the world
let's go
cool we made it all right we finished
the video game you guys roll credits
why is the camera so low
what specifically is low about it
what do you mean by low you mean in the
game
i feel like it's not that it's low it's
that it's zoomed in
if you mean my webcam i don't know what
you mean
hey big boys
i'm about to kill y'all
your entire family just all dead just
only you're just dead nope nope
cool r.i.p found its way to this
place of power everything with it the
fake
put your hands thank you the big d24
find answers to your own mystery
all right let's do it
sweet i did it bro are you happy
he really looks like he about to walk on
the normandy
codex of destiny
used to help the first fate readers
understand the nature of the weed
don't you see what this means
uh the world is changing i have broken
things by coming back to life i believe
you're the one changing it with every
breath you're changing how lives begin
and end this game
that's got to mean something too but
i'll be damned if i can read this thing
idiot as dangerous as an open flame
you could help people or destroy them in
time
when you get involved there's no ground
i love it i love it love to see it love
to see it
and that means oh i don't know i haven't
been checking
benjamin for uh achievements let's have
a look shall we
i have not gotten any achievements no
which well okay i feel like i should be
watching this it didn't pause
um but in theory the day one patch would
unlock the achievements right
but no i have not gotten any
i did that too soon i keep [ __ ] up
the fate leaving thing
so you should attack everyone first and
then do it
where i lost myself literally where am i
why is the camera now this zoomed out
is she fighting with us or against us i
totally missed the cutscene oh she's
with us
okay cool you guys great teamwork
love working with you oh
gotten any of them and everything
appears to be
at zero percent
which yeah generally that that will just
be fixed in a patch that stuff
it you don't have to redo it it'll
unlock
how do they find me i'm not sure but
they're very well informed about your
location
they came straight here from diagnosis
why are you here came to understand my
fate that's fair that's
is for fair like that codex you found
our scholars
but you're just full of surprises
the stone is simply embedded with what
they know cool why worry about the
little fish
when deeper waters hold them all there's
more to this than you understand
when you're ready we need the house of
ballads
i'm sure
sounds cool to me am i supposed to
follow her
no i'm supposed to talk to you but what
this dude got though
sweet a repair kit we can't trust her
she
okay perform your final rights my dude
have fun cool
i need to go sell some stuff again huh
uh how to get out
ha ha
sweet
uh lj scribe i don't imagine this game
will ever get a sequel
because there is no team to do it
is ultimately the issue
still don't know what to do here bro
fine
i'll respec eventually um
i mean that seems like a good thing to
have in general sorcery
how do i do i want
i guess i will just do this because you
know so let's go let's done
do that stay as the guardian beautiful
done so have i got i do
great work all round um can i fast
travel out of oh it's pretty close it's
fine
it's cool
it's all very pretty it's all very
pretty
i've been asked a million times but have
i played spirit fairy yet i actually
have a little bit on switch
uh it's gorgeous
okay
um yeah i definitely need to play more
of it only a tiny bit so far
but uh i really like it
very pleasant game
all right
back to the outside world we
[ __ ] go
attenber let's go
if this game 100 has feel like original
a fable from old school xbox
oh thank you for that uh should you
shower
yeah probably six days is a long time to
not shower full fam i feel like you
probably should shower
but um you know you do you
you do you
uh how we doing on main quests here fam
what
that's too many main quests look at all
of this what have i done
oh god
uh let's grab some [ __ ] shall we
i want to see what it looks like how do
they look though
they look pretty look at them
very pretty chakrams bro
we are gonna swap back though they're
not that it's just it's not
five percent health plus five health
physical damage damage freezing damage
they're actually pretty similar i'll
keep these ones for a bit because
they're prettier
i mean i'm not going to use any of this
[ __ ] i just don't want to get rid of it
because it's
it's fine once i get the chest none of
this will be difficult for me
cotton robes you say oh that's good
good mana regen though
i'm just gonna i'm gonna keep things how
they are for now
we're gonna stay shepardy
with the knowledge that at a later date
i will upgrade things you feel me
um talisman of mending
get rid of it
get rid of it get rid of it
okay
inventory management and then i have
some junk
so we're just gonna get rid of again
what i think is probably basic
[ __ ] that won't get me much money
get rid of this crude stuff fine that'll
do for now
uh where's my next quest
i don't have one equipped i feel like i
should stop there anyway you guys
um how is it holding up it's good
yeah i'm happy happy to be playing it
again i really do think that i don't
want to like get fully into it again
because there are too many goddamn side
quests
um but
combat feels great like honestly i
figured that this game would hold up
well because the combat is so solid and
always was so solid that i think kind of
no matter when you'll
when you play it it'll feel awesome so
definitely a thing
and i like it i'm a fan it's good game
but uh it is now almost 11 jesus
when did that happen oh wow it's only
been three hours
well two hours 40 minutes i didn't even
realize i was streaming for that long i
guess that means i really like this game
yes the actual subtitle of this port
hoffy is
re-reckoning which is very silly but
it's also from the same publisher who
did like
the dark side as like what is it like
war mastered and stuff
being uh thq uh
what improvements would i like in fable
um
i've said this for years and years now
dude uh
but hartman that i would like it if a
new fable had the kingdoms of amalor
combat system oh go to bed griff
gosh dang gosh dang
um all right everyone
thq did not get bought d
fire owner i don't know how to say your
name no thq closed
um and then nordic games
bought the name thq and became thq
nordic
but thq shut down and sold up all their
properties
so thq nordic and the old thq aren't
even the same person it's just they just
have the same
same name uh it's pretty uh
it's pretty dramatic stuff is there any
reason to get this version of the
original
uh i don't know i haven't played the
original since it came out it's hard for
me to say
other than i mean this is you know
optimized for modern consoles
seems to be a solid port that's all i
can really tell you
all right you guys have a good night
everyone
i will see you guys next time
you